we have more than the usual reasons to
love New York lately she's been battered
she's grieving and she fills her Island
with resilience and pride and the movies
have always loved New York it's the
naked city of eight million stories and
one of her long string of admirers is
with us tonight a New York landmark a
movie icon a filmmaker whose heart has
never strayed too far from the heart of
the city
this artist more than anyone else has
created a vision of New York that the
world has joyously shared and it is his
love for New York that brings him here
tonight ladies and gentlemen it is my
pleasure and my honor to introduce mr.
Woody Allen
thank you very much that makes up for
the strip search let me tell you why I'm
here exactly about four weeks ago I was
sitting home in my apartment in New York
and the phone rang and a voice on the
other end said this is the Motion
Picture Academy Arts & Sciences and I
panicked immediately because I thought
that they wanted their Oscars back
because I've won a few Oscars over the
years and I thought they you know that
they were calling to get them back and I
panicked because the the pawn shop has
been out of business for ages you know
and I have no way of retrieving anything
and they said no this was not it that
and I couldn't figure it out because my
movie the curse of the Jade scorpion was
not nominated for anything this year
nothing no category and then it suddenly
hit me maybe they're calling to
apologize you know and I remembered
during the course of the year I had been
walking on Fifth Avenue in Manhattan and
a homeless man came up to me and asked
me if I would buy him lunch and I didn't
buy a munch but I gave him fifty cents
and I thought maybe certain members of
the Academy had witnessed this and they
were going to give me a Jean Hersholt
Humanitarian Award
because that's what goes through your
mind you know I thought maybe that or a
Thalberg or something you know because
you start calculating you know I'm 66
years old a third of my life is over now
and I you know start to think maybe they
want to honor me but they said no they
said that here's what the story is in
view of the terrible events that have
occurred in New York over the last year
the Academy wanted to show support and
make a nice gesture and put together a
little film paying tribute to movies
that had been shot in New York over the
years and they wanted someone to
introduce it and I said you know God you
can do much better than me you know you
won't want to get Martin Scorsese or
Mike Nichols or Spike Lee or shouldn t
lament I kept naming names you know and
then I said look I've given you 15 names
of guys who are more talented than I am
and and smarter and classier and they
said yes but they were not available so
I you know for New York City you know
I'll do anything I got my tux I came out
here it's a great great movie town ever
since I was a little kid movies that I
grew up on in New York movies that were
shot there it's been a great romantic
and exciting backdrop for movies in New
York and and it's a great place to come
and work and make your movies because
it's still a thrilling and very very
exciting city in a couple of weeks I'm
going to be starting another movie in
the streets of New York I'm going to be
filming a romantic movie about a foot
fetishist interesting movie the Goten
the guy's a foot fetishist and he falls
in love with a beautiful Harvard
professor she's absolutely beautiful and
she's brilliant
and and she writes his paper on
existential philosophy and he becomes
sexually aroused by her footnotes you
know and I begin to sit a few weeks in
Manhattan so I plead with you to please
come make the films there is it remains
a great great city the film that you're
about to see now the clips will lovingly
put together by a terrific New York
filmmaker Nora Ephron and you can roll
this any time you want